as those copic numbers continue to get
better we're starting to see much more
activity on the las vegas strip
and resorts are reacting to that uptick
in demand orco mana joining us live on
the strip with the strip properties
and what they're now taking those steps
orco
well brian and denise resorts are ready
to rebound the encore
just announcing it'll start their
full-time operations
in april after months of midweek
closures
other properties are also offering huge
deals
in an effort to keep customers coming
it's been great to see a lift in
business over the last few weeks
the lights are coming back on in las
vegas as our covet 19 situation improves
more people are staying on the strip the
strat
already seeing a slew of visitors to
keep the momentum going it's now
offering getaway deals which include 30
off room rates discounts on
entertainment and skypod admission
we think these you know these offers and
these trips will
help us get in that direction so we're
looking forward to it
also a positive sign resorts are getting
rid of reduced hours the link now back
open seven days a week the encore is set
to resume full-time operations on april
8.
the properties in the strip becoming
fully functional again
is really the best sign that the demand
is picking up
and more people are coming to las vegas
tourists are thrilled
it's better to see things slowly
starting to adapt who knows when we'll
get back to normal officially but i hope
to see that normal somewhat soon
experts say it'll still be a while
that's why some properties are
prioritizing local
circus circus offering a 10 splash zone
deal for las vegas only
it's kind of our way of giving back and
saying thank you and we know that people
are trying to find different things that
they can do
everyone hopeful for the future it's
starting to feel like vegas used to feel
so it's exciting
experts say properties will continue to
offer special deals until
occupancy rates are high again for more
details on the deals available right now
head to our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live near the las vegas strip
tonight workout mana 8 news now